obviously this is a very sad day
everyone found out that David Bowie
passed away yesterday incredibly sad
news and he was he was on our show
several times over the years and the man
was always outstanding now today yeah
but people were remembering today but
people are remembering today what a
phenomenal musician David Bowie was and
of course that's was the case he was
just mind-blowing ly talented but in my
experience he was also an incredibly
nice person he was fun
he was always funny and we wanted to
take a second here and just look back at
a few of the fun moments I had with
David Bowie over the years you got the
coolest hair in rock and roll he doesn't
think so the guy there no he thinks he
can do a little better as Suzy has no
hair we share the same birthday sorry
all of us have the same birthday yeah we
yeah we were drinking buddies right back
haha I fly over to Memphis and we'd you
know go out for the night on the rez a
big Cadillac uh-huh is there any truth
to any of this no I was told I had to
ask I want to actually just just take a
brief walk down memory lane but first of
all just to look at some of the
different characters that let's put
these up because it's good to refresh
everybody's memory of course there was
the young David this is you early on
then there was Iggy Stardust of course
then there was the thin white duke of
course my personal favorite and then
there was a period there where you were
trying different you were trying
different personas don't do this to me
no I don't know other people remember
this we reviewed this once on the show
but you were you were trying to be
personas that I don't think quite had
the commercial appeal there was the
suave hunchback remember this at all
[Music]
yeah there was the buck-toothed wizard I
remember he was and then this is strange
here corn-on-the-cob period I found I
don't know about your name yes it's a
famous thing now that your name
initially Davy Jones yes it was Davy
Jones and in the 60s you had to change
it because the monkeys came along and
they were just getting popular when I
was just starting my career so I very
wisely changed it to Tom Jones true
story true story I was Tom Jones for
about a couple of weeks and just as I
was doing the photo session he released
his first record it's not unusual and so
then I moved on then you were David
Cassidy black tiger console you had a
songwriting contest a while ago yeah
tell us about that I didn't win you know
I find out about this contest and I'm a
bit of a songwriter and I thought maybe
you'd perform it right here and we'd see
who had the best song
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't mind do you
okay here we go
it's in G like GEHA I love to read
okay I'll live for G here we go oh yeah
I'll get you the moon there are so many
talk shows
[Music]
but he is clearly better than love
he's a handsome man but I'm not lying it
should be and and I'm not lying this
wonderful name is Conan O'Brien that's
the good part here here's the good part
crowd control
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you bust you g-string
[Applause]
no it is really weird cuz you'll just
walk by a TV set here and it's called
the feed and it's all the rehearsal and
you know the channels are on the on the
TV and there was Tom broke out right so
in like over 500 accidents of happen
this year anyway think about that Howard
she's 20 22 months now yeah and she saw
the moon we've got a kind of a Terrace
thing and we've out the other day and it
was still light but you could see like
that Half Moon thing yeah and she looked
up and saw it it's the first time she's
seen the moon that it's registered right
it's great when they're discovering
things like that for the first time it's
scary when they're like 20 you talking
about your your daughter do you sing
lullabies yeah a single mole of nursery
rhymes nursery rhyme yeah do you do it
in that David Bowie style or no but I
could do couldn't I cool if you went
into a room at night with a microphone
and you were just doing your guru - guru
do I see this one through a mouse ran up
the clock the clock struck one the mouse
ran down hickory
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I love them
[Applause]